[Musique]
et en 2020 on s'est tous bien fait en
tue mais avec le prélèvement à la source
et en cette rentrée on prendra bien
quelques mensualités laurent videur de
discothèque sa vie est devenue un
véritable calvaire
un reportage de jimmy fils d'or pour
papa vous allez olla monsieur à cheval
et à l'intérieur c'est que les habitués
monsieur bonne soirée mais j'ai des amis
à l'intérieur la blue lagoon été 2012
tu me connais tu marques à l'est parce
que j'étais à deux doigts de pécho
sophie branger allez hop ça dégage c'est
du sang non c'est de la merde
l'idée du meurtrier bizarrement on a
retrouvé notre adn un petit peu partout
là sur les lieux du crime
écoute moi bien si tu parles goethe
attachons roues du 4 4
je te trompe sur 200 m étais petit
couilles
jean-phi du saucisson la châtaigne a
compris ou pas les raisons francesca
c'est un suicide
d'accord
j'ai une margarita c'est pour moi hélas
oui merci
excusez moi je crois que votre sexe et
dans ma salade césar pas bon et voilà
par contre j'espère nous avait dit c'est
bah voyons